welcome hello my name is Trish please
come in to my living room smell it on
that's I like that one that's really
nice that's not too bad I make my own
soap and the reason why I make my own
soap is because i like to use cosmetics
and products are my skin because more
natural and a lot of stuff that you buy
in the shops is just full of chemicals
and and they're not what they say on the
labels
[Music]
[Music]
my living room is my life it's a bit
about what I treasure it's got photos of
my family my friends I like just having
things that I love around me
I have a tendency to leave the back door
open and they're walking and they walk
in bluetongue lizards
[Music]
these are a few of my special pieces
that I keep in my cabinet here this was
so glassblowing little wishing well that
I got made up for our wedding cake and
these were the flowers and these rachie
handmade these little roses but as the
years gone by they've gone discolored
unfortunately but that's still original
[Music]
mining out
[Music]
I'd like to say goodbye from myself and
my husband and from Perth Western
Australia it's been an absolute pleasure
having you here you're welcome anytime
thank you bye
[Music]